what's going on guys this is rob and the
new trailer for jurassic world dominion
just dropped not even a new trailer like
the trailer like a trailer for the movie
dropped
like the first trailer that we're
getting and i know jurassic park and all
that kind of stuff isn't really like
geek culture per se
but i mean we can cook the books or i
mean it's my youtube channel i can do
whatever i want here right so maybe this
is one of those videos just takes a
channel i have no idea but regardless
right there's gonna be a video like
nobody's gonna watch regardless i'm
excited man and you know why you know
why i'm excited here's the thing here's
the reason why this movie is going to
succeed man nostalgia that's why this
movie is going to succeed because we
just got awesome stuff here right i mean
like like it's what we've always wanted
from like the new jurassic park movies
right like dr sadler and and like dr
grant and like ian malcolm it's like the
only three people we've wanted in like
all the jurassic park movies right so
for those of you guys who never grew up
with drafts before i was born in 1984
right so i'm a 1990s kid right so like i
was i was what how old was i i was six
uh i want to say like eight or nine when
jurassic park first came out and like
when that movie was released it was
mind-blowing here's kind of a funny
thing too right some of you guys may not
know the technology they needed to make
jurassic park didn't exist at the time
and so they literally had to create that
technology right they had to create that
kind of stuff pretty much everything
that's happened
ever since then involving like the
evolution of special effects really goes
back to jurassic park i mean vacuum star
wars sure you have special effects but
those are more like practical effects
than anything else right little models
of like the death star and like shooting
it at certain angles and so on and so
forth but like jurassic park was one of
the first times it was just a wide
implementation of cgi in a movie it was
nuts right there's a there's like
there's a documentary on netflix or a
series called uh the movies that made us
or something like that and like one of
them's jurassic park and they're like
yeah man this movie changed everything
but uh but yeah no jurassic park the
first one was just phenomenal but the
first one just it was it was amazing
they won academy awards and everything
right movie was is absolutely
mind-blowing and i watch it to this day
matter of fact i'm gonna go watch it
right now uh because this trailer drops
right just like for the nostalgia of it
all but to be honest with you guys the
reason why this movie is going to
succeed is going to be because of
nostalgia right like nostalgia is going
to be the reason why this movie this
movie blows up i mean technically
speaking you did have sequels right
before you got like jurassic world you
got like the lost world jurassic park 2
which as a society we have all just kind
of silently agreed that the only good
part of that movie is when they're on
the island and like everybody's dying
and then like once you get to the point
where like they transition to the
mainland we watch it for a little bit
and then we all just kind of
collectively turn it off right and then
like go on to the next thing and no one
liked jurassic park three right no one
likes dress part the movie was awful
right movie was absolutely terrible but
having said that uh seeing like like
just just looking at the trailer seeing
like dr grant and like ellie sadler back
together again
god it just it brings back so many
feelings like so many nostalgic feelings
right because it's just like that's
where it started man that's where it
started right like like hammond sitting
in their trailer and just being like
like you know what what is it he said um
he was inviting them and they're like
well we know we're really really busy
and he was like well you know i could i
could you know like offer to fully fund
your dig and they're like
uh i mean i guess he's like for a
further three years though yeah right
because like paleontologists are broke
they're like one step away from being
homeless like all the like they
literally just travel around the world
and dig up dinosaur bones which don't
get me wrong
that sounds amazing
but literally as far as i'm aware they
just run off of like like donations
right just like people who fund their
projects colleges or otherwise and like
that's basically it uh at least as i
understand i could be completely and
totally wrong but i'm not aware of there
being like billionaire you know
paleontologists you know elon musk is a
paleontologist i'm not aware of that
right you know i mean it'd be it'd be
cool but i like i'm not aware that that
whole thing but like it's it's like it's
everybody's back right everybody's that
ham of course isn't back right the actor
died a long time ago but like
everybody's basically back you know like
bd wong is there with his long hair he
was kind of a dick in like the other
movies like that's one of the things i
didn't like about the the like of the
other jurassic world movies is they
basically made him like kind of a
villain you know and it's like i mean
he's he wasn't really a villain but he
was kind of a villain i'm not even
really sure i agree with where like with
100 of where he stands in the first
jurassic park movie he just seemed like
such a good guy you know like just a
cool guy who is doing some science stuff
and like the science stuff he did turned
out to kill people which happened
sometimes but like it was it was cool to
see like like for him in this movie it's
just cool to see him there i'm just
hoping they do a little bit of
redemption you know where he's not just
kind of like i mean yeah like we made
dinosaurs and killed people you know
because like hammond and those guys who
wanted them like bigger and better and
louder and so on and that's not really
how dinosaurs look because that was a
big talking point right that was a big
thing i don't remember it specifically
when i was a little kid but going back
and looking at it later one of the big
things that happened is when they made
jurassic world paleontologists
everywhere were like that's not what a
raptor looked like and and like in the
end i mean the movie made a whole bunch
of money and the studios don't care but
it's good to see that they like
reconciled that in the newer movies
where like bd wong was talking to that
one guy whose helicopter was attacked
and then he basically crashed into like
the whole habitat for the the
pterodactyls that just like spread and
started like smashing people up and
eating it but like he was literally
telling him he was like most of these
dinosaurs if we had brought them back
the way they were originally designed
they would look starkly different from
how they look right now like raptors
were like a lot smaller than the way
they look in jurassic park it was stuff
like that but all in all the trailer
just looks amazing it looks great and i
love that scene i love that scene when
they're all together i wish chris pratt
hadn't said anything right and here's
the thing you know just kind of an aside
here i want to see chris proud as like
an 80s action hero not even gonna lie
right like like my uh my chief chief
creative officer gordon he sent me this
this little scene where like chris
pratt's like squared up with like a
knife in his hand and like my first
thought is just like like dinosaurs have
basically spread across the world and
only one man can save us right chris
pratt with a knife it's like the most
1980s action hero scene ever right just
this still it straight up looks like an
arnold schwarzenegger film it looks like
something out of commando from like back
in the day nonetheless you know um this
you know seeing them all together and
like the t-rex is there and like both dr
grant and uh and chris pratt's character
i don't remember his name but like both
of them are there and they're like don't
move right like it's just this classic
thing right because like it's like the
best moment in jurassic park one let me
live
man i'm sorry so it's like the best
moment jurassic park one when the t-rex
comes out of the panic right and then
it's and then like literally like it
starts going after the kids and so like
dr grant grabs a flare and starts waving
it right and then like throws it and
like the t-rex goes running after it and
then ian malcolm ever the idiot like
gets out of the like literally ian
malcolm right this half idiot buffoon
gets out of the car gets out of the
truck with the flare and like hey hey
and then starts waving it at a like the
t-rex you know and then like dr grant's
like and freeze and then he was like
like like literally just like get the
kids and he's like get rid of the flare
he's like get the kids and then like
like grant's like get rid of the flare
so like literally ian malcolm's just
running and then he throws the flare and
the t-rex is like that's cool and then
like keeps chasing after ian malcolm
right and it's just it's like this thing
and then eventually like he ain't like
the t-rex catches up to him he ends up
getting knocked into the bathroom where
basically the lawyers hiding and like
the t-rex eats the lawyer like it's just
it seems like that right it's just it's
just these great call backs to the first
jurassic park and and for for me
personally like for a lot of newer
people right like the 12 year old kid
going to see jurassic world dominion
they're going to be like this is cool
dinosaurs are awesome for me i want to
be like yeah
nostalgia
that's exactly what it's going to be
like
dr brandt like i know like i almost shed
a tear man like it was all it was
it was like almost a little tear right
when you when like when like dr grant
and emily like ellie met up it was like
oh my god like it's just it takes me
back but regardless man this movie's
gonna be great right it's the old
generation meeting the new generation
and it's it's it's gonna be phenomenal
right i feel like ian malcolm is gonna
be like the best person in the whole
movie right where he's like i told you
guys life finds a way y'all didn't want
to believe me y'all didn't want to
believe me like like like hammond didn't
want to believe me nobody wanted to
believe me but i told you all it will
find a way right like what did he say
the first sriracha park uh he was like
he's like
he was making some kind of a speech
right but he was like you know like
change your life happens right it's it's
you know violent or whatever it is and
he's like yeah he's like then there it
is you know
and heaven is like there it is right and
it was just it's it's
i'm sorry i'm so excited people but it
is an exciting time right it's an
exciting time this trailer is exciting
this trail is really really cool it's
really really exciting kind of behind
the scenes video here i guess freaking
culture explain i'm really hyped about
it right it's just it's it's it's gonna
be great it's gonna be a great movie
i'm really excited to see it it comes
out in june uh yeah it's gonna be a
great film so anyway uh yeah thank you
guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace